I'm pregnant and you're asking what my
baby name is congratulations are in
order for Anne Hathaway who just
announced she's pregnant with baby
number two do you know what you're
having and I was like no and they were
like when they do I'm like May the
oscar-winning actress took to Instagram
to share the news with a black-and-white
pic of her growing baby bump I'm just
overwhelmed Hathaway captioned the sweet
pic it's not for a movie
hashtag number two you know if you read
her Instagram captions but they are
works of art her caption also alluded
that the process wasn't all that easy
writing all kidding aside for everyone
going through infertility and conception
hell please no it was not a straight
line to either of my pregnancy sending
you extra love I think that people like
are afraid to talk about pregnancy and
people are afraid to explore what's
possible and I understand why the 36
year old actress and husband Adam
Shulman shares son Jonathan who they
welcomed in March 2016 ET spoke with
Hathaway in 2017 about filming while
pregnant just before the birth of her
first son so I read that you were
expecting while filming this and it's
pretty physical yeah oh um you know I
couldn't do it the way that I normally
do it I'm I'm such a tomboy at heart and
so anytime it's like you know it's an
action scene or a fight scene or
something I always want to do it you
know just as fast as the boys strong and
I couldn't this time because I had a had
a little little person in my tummy and
so we had to and we did one take of the
fight because there's a big fight in
this and my my heart rate just sped up
really fast and I said okay okay guys
pregnant limitation we have to do it one
beat at a time and so we did and they
cut it together and nobody was the wiser
so so I would just like to encourage you
if you're the boss of a pregnant person
don't be afraid everything turns out
well V Adams
[Music]